all right this is just funny okay we're
gonna have fun now this is what fun
looks like when the country has been
partially taken over by lunatics uh
Marjorie Taylor green had another funny
gaffe where she has come out against
hiring based on ethnicity now you might
be saying well David what do you mean
what's ethnicity she clearly means
ethnicity but as usual has no idea what
she's talking about but she's against it
that's for sure you know private
businesses want to hire based on
characteristics and someone's ability to
do the job well no the Democrats and the
left want businesses to have to hire
based on skin color
um ethnicity or even what gender they
identify I would go further it's not
just that the woke left wants ethnicity
based hiring the left wants
ethnicimenticity based hiring and that's
the first question I ask on my job
applications when we look to hire people
what is your ethanamentous Center City
and of course Marjorie Taylor green very
well known for these sorts of gaffes at
one point she referred to a petri dish
as a peach tree dish you have to accept
the fact that the government totally
wants to provide surveillance on every
part of your life they want to know when
you're eating they want to know if
you're eating a cheeseburger which is
very bad because Bill Gates wants you to
eat his fake meat that goes in a peach
tree dish pizza you'll probably get a
little zap inside your body and that say
no no so there's Peach Tree dish also of
course infamously the gazpacho police
not only do we have the DC jail which is
the DC Gulag but now we have Nancy
Pelosi's gazpacho police spying on
members of Congress spying on the
legislative work that we do when she
said this I knew she was a real bisque
if you know what I mean and then this
one is not Marjorie Taylor green but I
just it's too good not to include
um Lauren bobert very famously coming
out against wonton killings they made
life hell on Earth with their Envy
wonton killing I don't know what a
wonton killing is
I'm gonna have to look that one up yeah
it's like attempted murder By broad
noodle is what I've read it uh it
actually works out too so anyway these
people are clueless that are clueless
about really important things but they
also just regularly make up words and
they're so confident that's maybe the
the saddest part of the entire thing you
know I have a very acute Newfound
appreciation for how busy being a new
parent makes you if you have a little
one at home like me here's something
really easy you can do to simplify your
life our sponsor little spoon is your
One-Stop shop for healthy easy meal time
and snack time for your baby toddler or
big kid delivered right to your door
little spoon delivers fresh organic baby
food which comes in single ingredient
varieties or multi-textured purees
little spoon is meals for toddlers and
big kids they're free of junk and taste
great even the pickiest eaters love them
I've even tried many of them I myself
they really are great having healthy
snack time is so easy with little spoons
organic smoothies which come in
convenient pouches in great flavors like
strawberry banana shake purple carrot
acai I love purple carrots I'm going to
admit that my girlfriend and I have had
a great experience with our little spoon
subscription it just makes life easier
anything to reduce the chaos is a great
thing little spoon is giving my audience
50 off your first order go to
littlespoon.com and use code Pacman 50
off all one word the info is down below